hey everyone Peter Combofiend roses here
to give you a breakdown on gokhan and
Ultra Street Fighter 4 Go Kids written
game has always been pretty decent but
his in close game was at Admetus that's
explorers changes to see whether he
gained the tools necessary to finally
hold his ground outside of gogans
counter he had no real attack that he
could rely on to prevent the opponent
from overwhelming him to help with this
his crouching light punch has been sped
up slightly but he can now turn the tide
when the opponents are relentlessly
pressuring him when faced against a
majority in the cast
gokhan lacked a way to punish unsafe
attacks thereby allowing his opponents
to run rampant against him to help
increase his ability to play a more
well-rounded game his first standing leg
kick has become special cancelable super
cancelable and focused cancelable with
this those fighting goken will have to
think twice about throwing off the wrong
attack or faced with repercussions go
kids ability to do damage from his low
attacks was severely underwhelming as is
crouching middle punch allowed opponents
to recover too quickly for his district
doll or any other special attacks the
combo leaving his only reliable low
attack in the form of his crouching hard
kick in order to give gokhan player some
more options the hit advantage on his
crouching medium punch has been
increased a bit so that when performed
his Atoka and other specials will now
combo gokhan ZX Tatsu was one of his
primary defensive moves in addition to
his VX counter however due to its high
propensity to go over low profile
attacks and it's slow startup it was a
high risk low reward attack that did
more bad than good to make this attack
more effective the startup of the attack
has been reduced while the hitbox has
been increased downward and in front
thereby increasing its reliability
overall gokhan has become much more of a
threat in Oak Street Fighter 4
you know how the tools to slow down the
opponent's pressure as well as the
ability to punish from slightly further
out the use he wasn't able to do for
with the increase in range to his DX
katsu opponents will have to think twice
about how they approach him or risk
being kicked to the face on the flip
side focus players will have to make
sure that they don't have used their
newfound powers
otherwise it could cost them
you